oh yeah we have a final trailer for war
for the Planet of the Apes I haven't
done a video on all the war for the
Planet of the Apes transistor this one
being the final one and I'm actually
saying it is the final one I want to do
us this trailer starts out Caesar and
his crew were going through this how
they're going into this house looking
like Rangers do they're all zero dark
thirty clear in the corner so you find
this girl in features like as you can
come with us she has no one else we're
not savages is that one egg that's like
bad human kill a prince eaters like that
him and he's like soldiers however you
look at the reverse it's like they're
soldiers looks pretty soldier to me do
what you have our two species who are
just they're fighting to survive here
species at war with each other the
winner will be the dominant species on
the planet the loser either going to be
slaves or wiped out completely
what a Harrelson with his speeches been
every trailer he has a new speech or at
least building on the last speech a show
from the previous trailer and this one
is like years from now when your
children ask you what did you do in the
greatest war you can say i-5 you look at
it this is the greatest war it's not the
largest scale war but it really is the
war that's going to define where the
future of the planet or at least a
species on the planet goes selfishly put
iris species almost like this I always
wonder like what about Islands what
about New Zealand I imagine they're
living in the Stone Age right now is
there a war with apes happening in New
Zealand or are they like well that kind
of stuff I guess we'll start over let's
just start over blending the rock making
fire Apes aren't everywhere I don't
pretend to know where apes are and are
not geographically speaking on the globe
you're saying there can't be a war
everywhere someone doing research and
Antarctica's like sweet I've got the
cure for cancer what happened to the
world I'm going to assume something
happens to that little girl that pissed
the Caesar off if I'm going to jump to
an assumption or conclusion I feel like
Woody Harrelson when he raids their camp
something happens to the girl pisses her
off he's just going to realize like oh
you don't care about human beings versus
aid you just want to win at any cost and
someone like that should probably not be
the dominant species on the planet
I like the Woody Harrelson breakdown -
he's talking Caesar he's like you're
smart as hell you're stronger than we
are humans seem to have more tech on
their side but if you have them toe to
toe
apes are going to beat human and Caesar
says what has been through all along
it's like
start this war but I will finish it
which is true he's like we apes we just
wanted to hang out and lube give you
guys pick the fight now here we are
fighting a war we have some turncoat
apes helping out the humans I'd like to
know their ideology I hope it's not a
case of parole judges Apes helping
humans I want that ape who's helping
humans to be like this is why I'm
helping humans guys in the end I know
that war for the Planet of the Apes is
not going to be the last Planet of the
Apes movie there's going to be a lot
more but as I've said before I see this
as a trilogy if they actually stick this
landing these Apes movies Rise of the
Planet of the Aged onto the Planet of
the Apes war for the planet of its solid
trilogy right there the rest after that
can suck if they want to as long as I
have my solid trilogy of the fall of
mankind and the rise of the age right
guys to the war for the Planet of the
Apes the final trailer have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]